mr pratt how are you sir tonight
entertainment
tonight
um congratulations sir thank you i'm
matt nice to meet you what's up matt how
you doing i'm doing very well how are
you doing pretty good man we're living
we're living the dream out here we're at
hall h and uh you know got tons of fans
all around and we're showing off the
stuff that we got to shoot over the last
year and we're feeling good man and it's
emotional it's emotional up there talk
talk about how it's so emotional and why
it's so emotional well you know
all great things come to an end and i
think we've built a really extraordinary
family over the past 10 years and
you know i know that term gets hack
needed and we all talk about it but it's
true man we've been through a ton
it's and and it just feels good and it's
also really
it's really cool to to do something and
sit back and see it for the first time
be like
oh my god that looks
that looks amazing i can't believe we
did that you know or james did it so
we're just grateful that james directed
all three movies and and yeah we're just
uh we're just lucky man i'm feeling a
lot feeling a lot i can tell everybody's
emotional did you get emotional saying
goodbye to this you leave these
superhero movies for your children does
that do you think about that does that
come into play as you say goodbye to
these characters
gosh it's a i i honestly have never
really thought about it that way uh you
know yeah you kind of
the exp that's
i guess so you watch the multiverse with
with your son and so like that made me
think like you're leaving these movies
we're gonna have them forever what does
it mean to you to leave it for your kids
i mean if my dad was a superhero listen
i i remember at the end of uh at the end
of guardians on my last day i gave a
little
speech to our our crew and our cast as
we were rapping out and i said like the
extraordinary thing is our name is on
this thing and it will be alive longer
than we will like one day i will be
we'll all be buried and gone and
our faces our names our contribution to
this piece of art will still be out
there that's really profound as an idea
i'm not sure we can really fully grasp
that what i end up saying goodbye to
what i'm saying goodbye to is is the not
the destination not the thing that we're
leaving for everyone to see but the
journey of getting there it's like that
journey is over and to me it's that's
really the extraordinary part of it for
these at least on the jobs that you
really like doing it you know some of
them the journey sucks and the
destination is great you're like yeah go
see the movie
that sucked
that guy was a pain in the ass but
that's not the vibe with us man it's
been a really fun
and that's why you're seeing people be
emotional because it's like
it's too almost too good to be true like
it's over it's sad you know it's sad
[Music]